this week we're talking about VMware
database choices and modernization I'm
Jen person and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news customers have been asking
us to provide broad support for VMware
and now with Google Cloud VMware
solution you'll be able to run vmware
vsphere based workloads in GCP this
means you have more choices for how to
run vmware workloads in a hybrid
deployment from modern containerized
applications with anthos to vm based
applications with VMware and GCP and
should those workloads happen to include
databases we've made a few upgrades in
that front to enjoy cloud sequel for
Microsoft sequel server federated
queries from bigquery to cloud sequel
and the ability to run elastic cloud on
GCP in Japan to learn more about how
each of these upgrades can help you
check out the full post one thing you're
sure to need no matter what security
read up on some recent improvements we
made from our advanced protection
program 2ml threat detection to new
locations around the globe where
heightened security keys can be used on
the cloud blog but first you've got to
get your workloads modernized and into
the cloud and that's why we've also
added new tools to make the journey even
smoother like support for migrating from
Missouri and tools to manage networking
for your micro services like traffic
detector now generally available and
layer 7 internal load balancer now in
beta see why each one makes such a big
difference on the GCP blog if you want
to read more about these announcements
or see a full list check out the link
have any thoughts or ideas leave us a
comment or tweet us we'll see you in the
cloud
you